bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bonjour
jimmy notre invité dans sa zone qu'a dit
ce matin et max orville bonjour bonjour
bertrand bonne année à vous mais à toi
bonne année à martinique première bonne
année à tout et auditeurs max orville
président du modem martinique modem pour
mouvement démocrate le mouvement
démocrate présidé par françois bayrou
mais vous êtes venu nous parler alors
bien sûr du modem martinique mais aussi
de re naissance renaissance qui a été
fondée créé il ya quelques mois
alors expliquez nous parce que vous
faites partie aussi de renaissance alors
c'est quoi cette deuxième partie
politique à côté du modem martinique
non pas du tout n'est pas question de
faire une accumulation de partis
politiques renaissance est parti de
l'idée qu'il fallait réfléchir au déclin
que nous constatons de la martinique de
ses infrastructures de deux sons de son
âme et nous avons pris l'initiative avec
d'autres bien sûr il y à quelques
militants du modem mais il ya beaucoup
de gens de la société civile et ceux qui
nous caractérise c'est que dans ce
mouvement renaissance et les questions
d'avoir des personnes de tout parti de
toute idée politique mais ayant des
valeurs communes comme j'ai l'habitude
de le dire nous n'avons pas les mêmes
idées mais nous avons souvent les mêmes
valeurs et renaissance était un moyen de
pouvoir réfléchir avec les citoyens et
de mettre sur la table et de permettre à
tous les citoyens martiniquais de
d'avoir une un avis éclairé sur toutes
les thématiques possible qui intéresse
les citoyens martinique on va y venir
donc vous en parlait comme un mouvement
c'est un mouvement en avant donc le
mouvement le modem le mouvement
démocrate qui est apparaissant smic
alors c'est un oui c'est pas un parti
politique mais c'est une coalition
politique c'est un rassemblement
ces sacs différents c'est un
rassemblement vous nous avez dit à peu
près de qui c'est un super bon citoyen
ce citoyen films et de partis politiques
aussi n'ont pas finalement
vous pouvez les gens du modem il n'ya
pas le modem dans le sens pas du tout
bahia par le parti mot no non non non du
doubs le parti ou des imams sont partis
nous nous partageons renaissance est un
groupe citoyen le rassemblement de
citoyens doit bien évidemment avec des
gens qui peuvent être encarté quelque
part mais qui qui dont la spécificité
c'est que nous n'avons pas les mêmes
idées et nous sommes à la recherche d'un
consensus est de faire peuple pour
avancer voilà alors justement
rassemblement de qui vous me l'avez un
peu d'écrits et j'allais vous demandez
pourquoi faire vous avez commencé
eh bien d'abord parce que vous le
constatez le vous les journalistes
nous avons une certaine idée de la
démocratie en ce moment nous trouvons
qu'elle est quand même assez écornée en
martinique le 14e du site dans votre
message de présentation de renaissance
vous dites qu'il s'agit de ne pas rester
au vieux sectarisme alors je sais pas si
vous pensez à quelqu'un en particulier
non non non parties en particulier où on
est parti mais en face on ne pas rester
au vieux sectarisme nous pensons qu'il
faut dépasser
effectivement les sectarismes pour
pouvoir se rassembler et comme je les
dis nous n'avons pas les mêmes idées
mais nous avons souvent les mêmes
valeurs
nous sommes un pays trop petit pour nous
permettre d'assister impuissant à ce
spectacle qui est navrant de voir que
nous ne pouvons pas nous l'avons nous
sommes dans l'incapacité de pouvoir
travailler ensemble c'est quand même
quelque chose qui me frappe
et entre nous nous avons une devise une
martinique unis rien ne lui résiste
alors qu un pays divisé et bien comme le
dit l'écriture et bien nous sommes
amenés à disparaître
donc je crois que le rassemblement de
toutes nos forces vives que nous
mettions
ban aux querelles pour avancer et dom et
donner une autre image de la martinique
et pour ce faire renaissance propose un
certain nombre de rencontres si on va y
venir on va y venir max orville c'est
encore un peu de temps mais bon vous
semblez vouloir dire qu'il faut innover
qu'il faut rénover aussi un petit peu
notre vie politique vous voulez y
participer avec ce mouvement donc
renaissance martinique
enfin jusque là on a vu peu de nouvelles
figures on a l'impression que vous
prenez les mêmes et que vous recommencez
quoi sous couvert d'une nouvelle
apparence mais sans changer les femmes
les hommes et peut-être même les
méthodes de la politique ici alors
personnellement la vo vous avancer parce
que non c'est ce que j'ai vu qui s'est
présenté mais maurice laouchez c'est un
peu des halles maurice là où chinois la
salle des jeunes si d'ailleurs de vos
invités
bertrand jour il faudra que vous veniez
me voir un petit peu et vous verrez que
il n'y a de nouveau visage d'accord et
de nouveaux usages comme on dirait aussi
là nous n'avons nous n'attaquons
personnes nous mettons des éléments du
débat
nous avons eu pour pour illustrer notre
propos
une rencontre avec des jeunes en
décembre un jeune il est en essence
génération entreprendre pour donner des
emplois voilà des employeurs et on nous
voilà avec dorothée de reynal présidente
du réseau entreprendre martinique est
leader et william k ster lauréats et aux
caraïbes 3d donc vous êtes parfaitement
qu'on donc déjà on a une tradition mais
si vous cherchez
non je vous cherchez des figures de
proue voilà les filières de poule et le
moment mais pas pour le moment nous ne
sommes pas dans l'incarnation de figure
de proue reconduire nous sommes drame
je vais je vais aller un peu plus dans
dans la question un peu poil à gratter
et polémique pourquoi pas moi j'ai
entendu certains faire le commentaire de
dire oui renaissance martinique ça fait
référence à au nom de la liste sur
laquelle vous étiez pour les élections
européennes où vous représentiez
l'as raismes la république en marche
puisque vous avez mission mais enfin
c'était essentiellement autour de la
reine la reine avait agir il y avait le
moderne et le modèle y avait aussi à
l'eau quand vous représentiez la
coalition exacte dont faisait partie la
reine et le modem est ce que renaissance
martinique c'est pas quand même le
cheval de troie de la république en
marche en martinique qui quand même à en
tant que tel a du mal à prendre ici quoi
donc est ce que ce n'est pas une manière
de
voilà d'alors contre un peu plus de
maquereaux nismo en martinique pas du
tout de toute façon nous ne renions pas
ce que nous sommes je suis président du
mouvement démocrate je suis membre de la
majorité présidentielle et nous
l'assumons donc à des alliés
effectivement de la majorité
présidentielle donc ça nous n'avons pas
de problème là-dessus renaissance c'est
effectivement ça peut être un clin
d'oeil je rappelle quand même et je
remercie les martiniquais que la liste
renaissance avait gagné en martinique et
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup en outre-mer
donc une renaissance comme son nom
l'indiqué bien ça nous à part dû être
aussi un clin d'oeil par rapport à une
situation dégradée c'est pas
spécialement labellisé majorité
présidentielle n'ont pas du tout puisque
encore une fois renaissance martinique
je voulais dit dans mon avant propos il
y a des gens qu'ils viennent de gauche
du socialisme des citoyens qui ne sont
pas encartés
il y a il ya certes un peu trop nisme
originel j'ai envie de dire si vous
n'êtes ni gauche ni droite à gauche vous
voulez nous plaît si fait normal que
j'en viens vous dit non parce que ce qui
est un pas il ya deux élections majeures
qui qui arrivent là mais la territoriale
et la présidentielle gens qui ont obligé
de j'entends bien que c'est con mais
j'entends bien que c'est votre actualité
que vous aimeriez bien que je vous dis
que je vous fasse un scoop pour la
matière pour l'heure ce sont des nations
là la situation de la martinique
nécessite que les citoyens martiniquais
s'empare des problématiques nous voyons
tous les jours un spectacle d'élus qui
nous ne nous affecte nous voyons la
problématique de l'eau qui dure depuis
onze ans je ne sais pas dans quel pays
du monde nous affrontons par exemple
exemple sur votre site de renaissance
martinique 3 janvier tribune de florent
grand bain eh bien vous voyez deux
précédents de l'association écologie
mama donc et au le carême est là et
voilà une longue tribune
évidemment où la ctm et bien les romans
étrangers peut-être son actuel comme
voit déjà vous vous pointer le doigt sur
quelque chose
renaissance donne la parole à des
formations à des associations citoyennes
donc vous voyez ne sera bien d'affairé
ouvert louis alors même là il n'ya pas
longtemps si alors docteur je la cite
ces publics entrera sur le net on va sur
votre site et on le trouve docteur
otilia ferreira manque de renaissance
martinique qui a été candidate
d'ailleurs que nous avions reçus dans
des débats à l'époque nous étions à
clairière a produit aussi un un article
enfin un article un texte on va dire
espoir le vaccin et la voilà qui prendre
un peu fait et cause pour wii wheel la
bastille nation donc aller
max orville président et que je modem
martinique mais ils manquent de
connaissances mais vous savez
concernant cette question de vaccins
tout à l'heure mais c'est l'actualité
donc dans votre journal j'entendais le
maire de casse pilote non c'est qu'il
installait un certain nombre de choses
et en même temps qu'il serait le premier
à vacciner bon pour une fois je le
félicite quand je venais jeu je prends
acte de cette volonté qui peut dire
aujourd'hui sérieusement que alors que
la pandémie a fait des millions de morts
dans le monde que nous mêmes en
martinique nous avons été affectés par
plus d'une quarantaine de nos
compatriotes qui ont perdu la vie est ce
que le vaccin ne constitue pas un espoir
je pense que raisonnablement on ne peut
pas dire le contraire est ce que c'est
la question du vaccin entraîne pour
l'instant une grande défiance de la part
de nos compatriotes
oui c'est vrai est-ce qu'il faut donc
plus mais non mais c'est la vérité oui
je voulais en même temps je mangeais
l'impression que depuis quelques jours
deux
moins en moins oui tout à fait mais
parce que justement on se rend bien
compte que il y à des avancées il faut
lutter contre toutes les théories vous
l'avez entendu du complotisme de
l'obscurantisme et c'est tout je n'étais
pas née autant de pasteur mais je
suppose que c'est parce que quelquefois
les gens pensent campagne de vaccination
ne veut pas dire cette application
obligation ni quand ni vaccination
massive non ça veut dire qu'on part en
campagne pour vacciner un certain nombre
de personnes qui ont été désignés on
sait par l'aco vide c'est plutôt les
personnes âgées ou sa religion c'est une
magie déjà c'est une particularité
forcément toute sa population maintenant
mais d'abord ça c'est d'une
particularité française
je rappelle qu aux etats-unis en
angleterre etc il ya une vaccination de
masse qui se fait la france a choisi
d'abord de vacciner si possible les plus
fragiles les personnes âgées
enfin les percées les soignants etc bon
on peut contester on peut dire ce qu'on
veut mais le vaccin est un espoir voilà
allez on termine parce que ça passe très
vite max orville vous nous parliez de
rendez vous que vous organisez rencontre
débat alors c'est grand public c'est
réservé aux membres de renaissance
emploi voilà voilà demain ya par exemple
une rencontre débat avec le chef de
corps du rsma de martinique
arnaud charbonnel sur le thème
l'insertion des jeunes martiniquais dans
la vraie vie
oui tout à fait renaissance comme je
voulais dit à innover ou du moins mis en
place tous les jeudis les jeudis de la
renaissance où nous traitons de thèmes
citoyen demain comme vous le signalez
nous recevons le chef de corps pour
évoquer l'insertion des jeunes dans la
vraie vie
donc c'est un espace lounge chair d'ici
là où chez à 18 heures c'est ouvert à
tous toutes les personnes qui ont envie
de s'intéresser à la question de
l'insertion des jeunes ou à d'autres
sujets la semaine d'après nous recevrons
josiane capron la présidente de la mp
nous recevrons gérard dorwling carter
sur la question de tous créoles
le recteur aussi dans nos horizons donc
venez tous au contraire rassembler vous
pour venir avec nous à renaissance mai
si max orville non merci l'espace
laouchez c'est les autres californie au
lamentin où l'ancien espace d'aider
l'ancien espace d'eads et voilà merci
bonne journée à toutes derrière ce merci
à vous mcsorley